CPR is a combination of rescue breathing and chest impressions.
It involves the compression of the heart between the breastbone and the backbone...
...and supplying oxygen to the lungs by blowing into the casualty's mouth.
Position yourself in a way that will allow you to apply vertical pressure during compressions.
Visualize the center of the casualty's chest and place the palm of one hand on that point.
Place the other palm on top of the first and interlock the fingers.
Alternatively, you can also grasp around the wrist of the first hand.
Either method is acceptable.
Deliver 30 chest compressions at the rate of not less than 100 compressions per minute.
Each compression should depress the chest 1.5 to 2 inches.
After each compression, release the pressure completely, allowing the chest to recoil.
After the 30 compressions, open the airway by lifting the chin...
...and tilting the casualty's head backwards.
Pinch the nostrils to close the nose and open the mouth with the help of the chin...
...to give two rescue breaths.
The two breaths should not take more than five seconds.
Continue CPR until the casualty wakes up, or advanced medical aid arrives.